che mi stava ammazzando che poi e roero
super credibile con la maglietta di
duffy duck lasciatemi sognare che cazzo
volete bella tutti ragazzi pervenute
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
cosa si chiama in inglese sarò vabbè lo
faresti oddio red bull fiorenti
all'inglese perché un cazzo mi hanno
fatto uscire a me dalle superiori non lo
so sarà mica al 51 e che mi è
accidentalmente caduto sulla scrivania
del professore può essere preferiresti
avere i piedi che puzzano o avere le
unghie lunghe unghie lunghe perché così
almeno mi taglio i piedi che puzzano
pesche bella cosa comunque a prescindere
miei piedi non puzzano perché io sono
fatto di lavanda gastrica però
preferirei essere un unicorno o un mago
tu sei un unicorno eri tu sei un
unicorno non hai capito un canon sai
come la storia in realtà è andata così
ovviamente un mago perché chi chi me li
pulisce gli zoccoli giace i piedi che
puzza ci mancherebbe solo che non riesco
pulirmi gli zoccoli prove prevedersi
combattere con un con uno squalo con le
braccia da da da orso va bene quante
speranze o di vincere o combattere un
orso con le braccia la squadra non
celare le braccia lo squalo quale
braccia squalo che non ha le braccia
fantastico preferiresti avere una casa
nel mezzo della città oppure miglia
miglia lontano dalla città in realtà
ragazzi questa cosa una cosa che mi sono
sempre chiesto visto che ho cambiato
casa spesso il fatto è che quando tu
cambi casa vorresti andare allora io
personalmente a me non piace il casinò
no quindi io starei molto volentieri
fuori dal bordello per c'è traffico
casinò quindi o preferirei stare in una
casa che sta fuori dalla città il fatto
è uno questo invito nell'ano vitobello
un dito di shrek nell'anno non il mio
dito che magro il dito proprio di shrek
il dito di shrek nell'anno di stare in
una casa fuori dalla città e che c'è una
linea internet che è paragonabile alla
velocità che a mia nonna nel raggiungere
il frigo la mattina e questo è un
problema perché devo stare la forza in
città al centro dentro il duomo perché
sono non arriva la fibra fantastico che
mi fa schifo però
bastardi marca mente internet fuori
dovresti avere una ford o un ace vi
guarda sei invece io che cosa preferirei
avere preferirei avere la patente prima
di tutto port kadima e valència
maledetta investita da un tram una posso
cliccare in mezzo
me l'ha data e la patente se dico ford
bene preferire si conoscere il tuo idolo
oppure essere popolare a scuola chi
cazzo si incula essere popolare a scuola
di questi tempi non lo so quindi la
prima tutta la vita preferiresti perdere
un occhio e una mano oppure una gamba e
un orecchio ma il tipo che chi ha fatto
stato mandati che problemi al cern c'è
infatti vedendo uno psicologo buono è
anche perché sennò gambe orecchio anche
perché non essere però va bene per i
essi prendere ricevere 20 dollari oppure
ricevere i complimenti di continuo per
un giorno 20 dollari
bisogna scrivere fa vj sei un grande e
fa i geni si un mito del da sganciare
stephen di euro a testa ai quei domani
compro lo yacht
poi mi scrivete precise un grande domani
però preferirei essere il personaggio
del tuo videogame preferito o del tuo
film preferito allora videogame
preferito metaldi a e se fossi solid
snake per chi non conosce metal gear
avrei una malattia che mi fa invecchiare
tipo in cinque minuti diventa un barbone
non mi conviene tantissimo non so qual è
il mio film preferito è mio film
preferito
harry potter concas che prendono metalli
a prevedere se avere capelli lunghi fino
a terra e non tagliarli più essere
pelato capelli lunghi fino a terra che
mi decidevo frustare tutti i miei amici
50 per cento le ferie sti passare una
giornata intera da solo sotto l'oceano
oppure spendere un anno dall annuncio un
giorno avevo letto sbagliato
dove un anno un anno nel sottomarino
cougars oppure un anno da solo nello
spazio assolutamente la seconda saranno
tipo 82 per cento la seconda scommettete
69 scusa non avevo tenuto conto dei
desideri sessuali della gente preferisce
avere un pick bismark chi cazzo è un ds
è la madonna che cazzo è che copra il 78
per cento della tua faccia fra te tu sei
sottovalutatissimo kakà nessuno oppure
avere due foot tail credo che siano
delle cose e cos'è una coda non è
neanche così male in realtà la coda
assolutamente a cosa è [ __ ] non è anche
abbastanza sexy una tipa sarebbe
sexyssima ragazze se volete rimorchiare
me quest uomo bello che ha solo una cosa
che li copre il 3 per cento della faccia
abbiate la coda che è più bello
preferiresti pisciare senza fermarti per
il resto della tua vita oppure piangere
senza fermarti per il resto della tua
vita tra i passare anche per un
sentimentale ragazzi ma chi cazzo prendo
in giro che voglio pisciare davanti a
tutti ma mai così sulle scarpe dei miei
amici pa affanculo dopo che vi
schiaffeggio con la mia coda lunghissima
preferiresti parlare leggermente troppo
forte o leggermente troppo basso troppo
poco io parlo basso parlo nano io già
parlo così quindi ma che cazzo chiedo a
fare forte forte 44 per cento domini
preferì lessi indossare i tacchi oppure
indossare un vestito domani e scovo i
tacchi non è più figo preferiresti avere
due milioni di iscritti su youtube o
avere un milione di follower su twitter
grazie a tutti grazie a tutti è il terzo
adesso che tutte queste 900.000 persone
today the grazie è che che mi fate
popolare su youtube sul sito bello dei
video trieste essere essere ciccione
come peter griffin ma molto in salute
oppure intonato no tonificato che cazzo
vuol dire ton ed ovviamente peter
griffin tutta la vita sto scherzando
preferireste essere famoso su tumblr su
youtube basta ricordarmi quante gioie o
nella vita perché ci sono i famosi su
tumblr non lo spiego sta cosa
youtube perché non ricevi money su
tumblr altri 950 mila haters da
aggiungere
alla cifra di preferiresti essere
l'uccello di twitter oppure il panda nel
vvf mio modesto parere il panda del web
e al suo fascino panda le vv.f non
capite un cazzo preferirsi sposare una
persona del sesso opposto che non può
cucinare pulire o lavorare oppure
sposare una persona dello stesso sesso
che fa tutte le cose e le fa bene allora
favi gates con il sesso vince chi se ne
frega mangiavo merda per il resto della
vita ma almeno si bomba preferiresti non
sapere come leggere o non sapere come
scrivere avrebbe stato un casino
raggiungere questo sito senza saper
leggere ma anche senza saper scrivere
soprattutto andare a rispondere al
citofono sarebbe grave come scrivere
mandiamo a rispondere al citofono
preferirsi combattere contro hulk hogan
o contro the rock dal cogan forse si è
leggermente arrugginito lo spero e dio
hulk hogan preferiresti essere un orco
un elfo della notte va assolutamente ma
tutta la vita nella vita elfo della
notte mica quanto sono figlie filano cup
ci vuole essere norco e mangi come la
merda poi ti dipingi di verde fi prim
preferiresti essere un uomo un elefante
home a un topo nelle maglie o il mouse
nuovo estero mouse non vuoi essere
toccato dal mio dito ogni volta che
dicono ora mauro emmaus 10th condito con
il mio dice grazie alla house tutta la
vita altre domande professi essere nudo
sempre ho mai lasciare il tuo
appartamento domande tutte nude di
arresto e ne vieni che facciamo le cose
tutte gay se dite se è di tebe stesse
l'australiano americano americano perché
se non hanno tutti i ragni così webber
che a [ __ ] vanamente ora vedete si sia
già pensato la palco i ragni così
austria chiti manola traiani in merda
resti essere avere gandalf come tuo
nonno o silente così lenta che le sente
fare magie però gandalf
se io non mi ha guardato il potter rogan
da quella porta la porta la porta e
veloce veloce brave
vabbè ragazzi direi che dopo aver
cacciato i miei amici di casa per ovvi
motivi ovviamente
che avrete capito tutti sicuro direi che
posso concludere qui i video quindi
ragazzi che un crudo vi episodio di vg
come siano sicure da non ricordo mai
santo in chi io non so perché non me lo
ricordo che non ci sia nessuna parte
però i 900 ragazzi cosa senza misura sul
momento è un mi piace abbiamo scelto
facebook e con iniziale se sì siete lì
ci vediamo così un video da ragazzi